*générique un peu mal chanté*
*bruit de zombie*
*musique de type antillaise*
3, 2, 1, top
*rires*
Et je vais vous enseigner des méthodes simples pour vous sortir de... "rires"
Je serai assisté par Noël
Je crois qu'j't'aime plus.
On peut baiser quand même ?
Nan mais il a pas pu faire de constat parce que... Tu peux pas faire un constat avec un chevreuil
En tout cas je suis content de t'emmener ici.
*rires*
- Qu'est ce qui se passe ?
Euuuh.. Rien, alors pfff beaucoup trop pardon !
Direction le PytTHON !
Nul à chier
*rires*
MON FRIC PUTAIN !!! MON FRIC...
*cris*
Ça tourne !
Une petite polka !
Passer tes journées et tes nuits entières à servir du vomi et.... *rires*
Nan, on a arrêté ça, servir le vomi; personne n'en achetait donc euh... *rires*
J'ai fumé mon pouce jusqu'à 8 ans !
Du tennis ?
Mais nan du jet-ski !
Mais évidemment du tennis ! Oh putain... *rires*
Eh oh !! C'est lui qui *cafouillage*
Ooh je deviens fou ça y est ! *rires*
*bruit de claque*
Attendez !! Nan nan il y a un malentendu là !
*rires* - Tu m'as niqué la lèvre !
*rires* - Il est en train de mourir !
Salut !
Aïe !
*rires*
- Bon bah c'est pas tout ça... On s'est bien fendu la gueule, j'ai perdu mon micro; et je vous emmerde ! *rires*
* chanson : ''il a mis son sexe'' *
(meilleure chanson de l'univers par ailleurs)
(merci)
- Le casque ! Le casque ici, le casque !
*rires*
La plus belle bite
De France et d'Outre-Atlantique
Bam sur le cul !! Bam sur la chatte !!
*rires*
J'arrivais plus à bander et puis bah euh... Mon sexe gaugeait dans le sperme quoi ! *rires*
- Pfff *rires* "gaugeait"
- Le con !!
- Man ?
*rires*
Par contre j'ai pas de crayon.
MOI !..
*crie*
*rires et cris*
Réfléchis, si je te réponds pas, c'est ptet que j'ai pas envie de te parler, voilà
*camion qui passe*
Bon, ce camion fait un peu de bruit, voilà, merde
Donc je te "casse les couilles"
Super.
Et la chemise elle est d'époque ?
*bruit de zombie*
*rires*
C'est "l'homme le plus hater du monde", ou "le plus gros hater du monde"?
Le, "l'homme le plus hater du monde".
Merci.
Tu devrais le savoir, on l'a écrit ensemble, connard
Ah ouais ? Tiens, regarde !
*rires* quel connard
... décalé ?
*rire bizarre*
*bruits de réunion*
Aaah, l'huile d'olive Puget
haha
CHUT
oh. rrrrrrrr
ouais c'est chaud là, j'aime bien
grrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr
Putain, à 3 je la...
grrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr
à 3 je ronronne !
miaou
Ok, niquel
Ça y est je bande putain
*rires*